I had 12 I visas when I got out of the
hospital I couldn't walk there's times
where I just thought about giving up and
just thought it's never gonna get better
may 2014the shocking images of deryck
whibley laying unconscious in a hospital
bed spark headlines around the world you
wake up in this hospital you're looking
around we thinking um I sort of know why
I'm here my mom was there so I knew
something was bad because she lives here
I'm right it's Angeles so when I open my
eyes and my mom was standing over me I
knew something was bad seventeen years
of partying spending up to $1,500 a week
on alcohol vodka every single day Derek
became the poster boy for not taking
care of yourself he had nerve damage in
his feet and almost died five times this
terrifying reality caused that rock
bottom moment but he collapsed in his LA
home I've ended up in the hospital liver
and kidney failure and it was a better
like a year and a half two year sort of
recovery process from that throughout
the struggle derek was supported by many
including ex-wife Avril Lavigne who at
the time tweeted that she spoke to sum
41 Derek today I am so proud of him he
is family to me and always will be
hashtag stay strong Derek you must have
had the huge support system to help you
out you said yeah my mom my wife yeah
and some clothes people in my life
because like you said that does that
could feel like an eternity if you're do
going to this role for the first time no
one's around to cheer you on encourage
you yeah there was a lot and you know
what else helped a lot was reading a lot
of messages from fans so just
it was just a really nice feeling to me
to read all these messages because
they're really heartfelt and it meant a
lot